("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
I don't think people
realize how much money
I'm leaving on the table.
For humanity,
for my legacy,
for the good stuff.
You know, being an interesting
human being is a thing.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And so like the biggest thing
I think that people the biggest
downfall is lack
of self-awareness.
Like who wants to sit there and
say I'm just not interesting,
cute, smart,
clever, you know, enough.
- [Man] Yeah.
- We all have
different paths, right?
We all have different paths so
I think the mistake is
lack of self-awareness.
The next biggest
mistake is lack of patience.
And I think lack of patience
manifests in couple place.
So you have the horrible version
of lack of patience which is
somebody's like
completely tone deaf.
- [Man] Yeah.
- They think they're GaryVee
or they think
they're fucking Beyonce.
They're the
people on American Idol
who are not
doing it for schtick.
They like literally think that
they're fucking unbelievable and
then they sing and they're shit.
- [Man] Yeah. (laughs)
- So there's that but I actually
think there's another version
which is I think a lot of people
that actually follow me because
I kind of suffocate the
other crowd out pretty quickly,
there's other places
to go if you want to
be completely tone deaf.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Which the people that are
actually slightly empathetic and
they realize they're trying
to be an influencer and they
realize there's some baggage
along with that and they're
actually empathetic to what
their friends are
saying behind their back.
And the problem is you don't
go from 0 to 100 in one day.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You have to be able to
eat the shit of the voices,
you have to be able
to accept the voices,
you have to be empathetic to
your buddy who's like who the
fuck do you think you are?
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- What the fuck are you doing?
- [Man] Yeah.
- You have to
be able to do that.
That's what the early
pioneers of reality TV did.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- That's what
the Kardashians did.
You have to be able to when
everybody says you suck to know
that you're not.
- [Man] Hmmm.
- And that's hard.
- [Man] Yeah.
- Especially when you have to
go a year or two or three before
you actually get to the
place to prove them wrong,
that sucks.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And that is my gift.
I love being an underdog.
I hate that I'm starting
to have my moment.
I liked it a year
ago when it was still,
I knew it was coming.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] And a lot less
people knew it was coming.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] I think
a lot of people are
starting to know it's coming.
Let's go.
Intent is the North Star
of this entire conversation.
- [Man] Intent.
- Yes. The intent.
- [Eliot] You don't need
sound off but when post it.
- [Gary] Yep, thank you.
Know for all the admiration of
every 24-year-old that's coming
my way, there's a big part
of me that doesn't like it.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] Because I
like being underestimated.
I could never sell
the things I make fun of.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] I feel
like I'm not selling.
I feel I'm documenting.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] I'm aware that it's
leading to things but it feels a
lot better than the people
that pay me are (censored).
You know, I don't feel
good selling a $9,000 course.
Any industry where the majority
of the winners and players are
doing things that are selfish
for themselves and not for their
client is a vulnerable industry.
That was the high-end
wine business years ago.
That's why I won there.
That is the agency
world today in marketing.
That's why I'm winning there and
neither one of them combined is
as bad as football
agents are to their players.
(laughs) I mean it is...
- [Man] Yeah.
- The part that people
fundamentally confused about me
is for some reason they forgot
that I spent 13 years building a
humungous business and
didn't say one word to
anybody ever about anything.
- Right, that makes sense.
- The end.
I'm actually a businessman.
I moonlight as GaryVee.
- (laughs) That's
a good way to put it.
- That's it.
- That's a good way to put it.
- GaryVee's Batman.
You know what I mean?
Kinda thing, you know?
- Yeah.
- That's the
confusing part about me.
- Mhmmm.
- That's why I'm
pushing the kids to build
actual things and patience.
If kids, how old are you?
- 33.
- You know what
I'm about to say.
We're perfect
'cause I'm 41, you're 33,
and they're 22.
- Yeah.
- This is perfect.
- Can you believe how
young you feel right now?
- Yeah.
- You would've
never thought that at 22.
- I know.
- The end.
Got good news for you, you're
gonna feel the same at 41.
- Love it.
- (slaps table) That's it!
- Love it!
- That's the fucking game.
Headed to Yankee Stadium.
Portuguese Wonder is here.
How are you, man?
- Great.
(inaudible) This feels good.
It's gonna be cool.
(Gary laughs) Some 40 hours
of editing or something.
And then I sent it
and I was like okay.
That's it.
Maybe they won't
reply, I don't know.
Maybe they will but it's done.
And then you just,
really completely
above my expectations.
And it was funny, there was
a couple of friends of mine,
they were like we didn't
have any idea what you do,
did you send him an email asking
him if he wanted to do it?
And I was like fuck, no.
I did it.
I took a chance.
It worked.
- It's always the
answer, isn't it, Tyler?
More, more, more.
Just do!
- Do!
- Just do!
- Maybe you get
something, maybe you won't.
- That's right.
- But you will get something.
- You know what's funny?
- Yeah?
- You probably never would
have got an answer to the email.
- Of course!
I wasn't expecting.
- You know what I mean though?
But the fact that you took the
way bigger risk, you did.
Obviously, you love
doing it so that makes it fun.
- Yeah.
- It's always better
when that's the case.
It's cool, man.
So what's happened?
Have people pinged you?
What's been happening?
- The buzz
that's appeared,
I'm doing my own thing now.
- So awesome.
- Video, I'm a DRock or Tyler.
- Yep.
- Or a Staphon in Portugal.
- For people.
- For yourself?
- I am actually exploring.
- Both!
Both!
- Exploring the DRock concept.
- Yeah.
- Sorry Tyler. Overseas,
I'm speaking to influencers,
Portuguese influencers.
Tell them I can do this for you.
Nobody's doing it in Portugal.
- That's so crazy
you said that yesterday.
Nobody's doing what we're doing.
- No. Nobody has the shadow.
Maybe some people
do vlog but it's like--
- Right.
- When you vlog it
yourself you have to be like,
you don't have to be but if
you're like Casey when the
quality for 10 minutes
is there but most aren't.
It's just somebody
speaking to the camera.
- And by the way, most
people aren't going to do
well being shadowed either.
You have to have it, too.
Which is?
- Which is, "I'm gonna."
- Oh, I remember.
Fuck you're gonna, right?
- Fuck you're gonna.
I want to build
my personal brand,
I want to be my own.
- I get it.
You can do both.
- I can do both, no, no
but that's what I'm saying.
- I do both, right?
I do marketing for
myself and we do marketing,
you know?
- Yeah.
- I do both in a weird way.
I like that you peeked.
("Honey" by J. Rhodan)
Calls, calls, calls.
That's like more, more, more.
(laughs) Jersey, Jerz.
Okay, cool, great.
Let me know.
I'll talk to you later.
- [Woman] I was out
here waiting for the ATM,
I was wondering if I
could get 20 for two 10s.
- 20 for two 10s?
- Yeah.
I want it from the ATM.
- [Gary] Why?
- Because it's new.
It's for a gift.
I don't want it
like bent or anything.
- I just took a bunch
of 20s out of the ATM,
is that good?
- No, I'd rather go that one.
- I don't want to do that.
- [Woman] Don't want to do that?
- [Gary] No.
Sometimes you just got
to go with your intuition.
(indistinct chatter)
That's song's been saved.
Shoot for the fucking moon.
Because the stars are better
than if you shot for the clouds.
'Cause you shoot for the clouds
you're gonna end up on the roof.
It's the words of
wisdom from Uncle Gary.
(group laughter)
Your Grandpappy Gary.
Old World Gary.
I know there's some
old timers watching,
I got you.
Your buddy Gary.
In Jersey,
I'm super close to
Edison, New Jersey right now.
It makes me happy.
Feeling those Jersey vibes.
("Honey" by J. Rhodan)
One of the biggest
things is managing efficiencies.
One of the advantages, to your
point and I've been thinking
about this, one
of the advantages
that Team Gary has is
if you're not doing something,
which is almost never,
but if you're not but if you're
not, I'll lose my shit if you're
not making, make me an
animated GIF mother fucker.
Like if Steven Spielberg
worked on Team Gary,
I'd be like where's my
fucking Instagram story, dick?
Need people to be like fashion.
High, low.
The number one thing
happening in fashion right now,
it's been happening
for a while is
women mainly but men too,
they'll wear a
$1,700 pair of jeans
and a $1 t-shirt.
Right?
And the handbag's $7
and the glasses are $17,000.
We need that.
That is what I have.
It's not that Babin
and DRock are so special,
it's that that's the religion.
You might make
an animated movie,
you might make an
animated GIF and that's that.
And so as long as the animator
with downtime is like fuck it,
I'll just make some, I'll make
17 animated things today and we
can put it out on social.
I know what to do and I got
to change a lot of rules but
("Honey" by J. Rhodan)
Everybody's, you
see where I'm going?
We're fixing the
airplane while we fly it.
(laughs)
By the way, by not
taking a stop in
Providence, Rhode Island
to fix something and then
Kansas City, Missouri we've
lapped the world 15 times while
everybody's still fixing their
brakes in fucking Wichita.
PureWow now for
a series of meetings.
As a lot of you guys
know, we bought PureWow,
women's publishing company.
Modern media company.
Very excited about the
acquisition and the team.
Ryan Harwood,
the CEO, unbelievable.
Mary Kate,
Editor-in-Chief, unbelievable.
Really excited about the
strategies we're
putting in place.
Life is good there.
That was a good, big purchase.
And it's going to
continue the process of winning.
I like winning.
There's always
a ying and a yang.
The great promise of the world
that I saw isn't gonna happen
because people don't have the
self esteem to put themselves
out there to have
a real conversation.
That's how
you're on the same team.
(censored) needs to be part of
(censored) and (censored) and
(censored)'s world
and that's that team.
- [Nate] Yeah.
- We're also gonna
produce a lot more content.
I've got something
weirdly figured out.
We can't lose twice.
If you're gonna put
people in these slots,
the output has to show it.
There's something I'm
seeing that I'm excited about.
- [Woman 2] Yes.
- Like, let's just produce
a shitload more content.
- [Nate] And how
we get paid for it?
- Of course, of course.
If we produce it (censored),
I know what I'm--
- [Nate] Yeah.
- Right now, we're
losing on both fronts.
What I define as emotional
intelligence self-awareness,
empathy, gratitude are
absolutely three things that
emerge immediately
when I think about them.
And I think it manifests in
the environment in the workplace
more than people realize.
I think it's the game.
Honestly, I think
it's the whole thing.
I just think it's
the whole thing in life
let alone fucking work.
So, I think it's
why I'm able to be me.
If I wasn't empathetic people
that troll me and don't believe
in me and think I'm the bad
version of the good version that
I am would have
stopped me from doing.
Just had two great meetings
with the PureWow team on
two major different objectives.
Now, we're gonna have
dinner together as a team.
Continue to bond.
When you make these integrations
you have to massively over-index
in the beginning of any
important integration when you
buy a company of the size of
PureWow which is a sizable
business, the biggest
business I've ever bought,
you got to triple down
and so you got to do
9 P.M. to 11 P.M. dinners.
You got to do them often and
early and with passion and focus
and so time to put
the beanie on 'cause
that's when I get serious.
Good day, just
fucking doing it, you know?
Guys, doin' it.
Love you for your comments.
Enjoy it
and I love you guys back.
When I say I'm an anomaly, I'm
empathetic to what people may
think about that but to me it a
bigger sense of responsibility
to make sure that people that
are looking at me don't become
crippled trying to
replicate it if they don't have,
I have natural
energy out my ass.
- [Erik] Right.
You're passionate
for what you do.
- Pure fucking passion, man.
Just really, just knew
how it was going to play out.
You know?
I want you to be bought
into the religion.